عليه افضل الصلاه واتم التسليم في يوم
كبير من ايام الوطن المسلحه في يوم كبير
من ايام الهجانه اليوم
تقريبا
استيلاء عليكم كل ما هو موجود في المعسكر
الخاص
بقوات
التمرد في
قطاع كردوفات ودي
اصاله وقوه ومتانه جنب القوات المسلحه
ودي اصاله ومتانه وقوه جندي الهجانه
الحجامه والهجانه ومريس الهجانه الكلام ده
حقها والناس بيقولوه من يوم عملوا القوات
المسلحه
حق الشعب والجيش حق المواطن لكن القوات
المسلحه عولتني انها هي لا تتهاون ابدا في
حفظ امن واستقرار هذا الوطن العزيز اللي
هو
مواطنه وشعبه ويتمتع بافضل الاخلاق باحسن
الصفات لذلك بيستحيق انه هو يكون عايش في
امر ويستحيل انه يكون عايش باستمرار ودي
القوات المسلحه اللي هي العامه الجايه
بتكمل 100 عام بتعمل على هذا الكلام منذ
غشاءه حتى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذلك
الامر لانه ده واجبنا ودي مهامنا يكفينا
لنا القانون يكفينا لنا الدستور وما حد
يتخلى عنها ابدا لحدي اخر يوم من حياته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات